[Musique]
les parisiens ont été condamnés à faire
surface ils ont donc ressorti pour
l'occasion le bon vieux système d qui
chez nous à solide réputation et qui
marche
regardez plutôt ce reportage de
françoise champeaux le moins que l'on
puisse dire c'est que aujourd'hui les
parisiens avaient fait preuve
d'imagination et de courage
depuis longtemps de minutes
non mais vous allez vous tous
ouais c'est assez classique là on marche
pas très vite
[Musique]
le vélo de tremblant investissements la
balance mon enfance à l'étranger pas je
vais pas d'autres moyens non j'ai pas
trop dur
de temps en temps bonne route
merci
[Musique]